how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we have some truly
exciting news talking about Wolverine in
the MCU and Alpha Flight in the MCU and
even talks about the Hulk vs. Wolverine
happening in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as well we know that the
mutants are coming and we know that
eventually Wolverine will be introduced
into the MCU but how exactly are they
going to do this well we have some
details about how exactly this could
happen from a report several several
months ago to go along with these new
reports that we got today so I'll break
down everything that you need to know
but first big congratulations to Scott
ralads for being last week's winner for
our Funko pop Black Widow giveaway just
email me in the email in my about Me
section and we'll get you your Funko pop
and for this week's Funko pop giveaway
it's going to be a Wolverine Funko pop
so all you have to do to enter is
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment about the video down below so
today we have many reports from many
different accounts including the Twitter
account of Kaleb Williams
editor-in-chief of Knight edge media and
the direct calm both stating that Alpha
Flight is coming to the MCU soon and
this is really exciting news because not
only is Alpha Flight a really cool team
but it probably means Wolverine is
coming as well especially when we go
over the original report that said the
Alpha Flight is coming into the MCU we
get a lot more knowledge on what exactly
is going to happen so way back in
September of last year
Mikey Sutton reported that Alpha Flight
will be coming to the MCU now this was a
two-part report and the first part was
that Marvel Studios is talking about
making a Hulk vs. Wolverine film and the
second part was about how the story is
going to play out and he started it off
by saying that the Hulk that's going to
be in a Hulk vs. Wolverine film is going
to be based off of immortal Hulk so very
different than Professor Hulk which we
got in Avengers in game he goes on to
say how the Hulk and Wolverine run into
each other apparently the Hulk is going
to be on a mission to go get Wolverine
in Canada but when he gets there he runs
into Alpha Flight who has also been
looking for Wolverine as well and this
ends in a big battle between Alpha
Flight and the Hulk now again this was
reported back
in September of last year and now we're
getting reports that we could actually
see Alpha Flight relatively soon
so perhaps Marvel has decided to
introduce Alpha Flight steam before they
introduced the Hulk first Wolverine
story that way when the Hulk and alpha
flight fight we actually know who the
team is in the comics alpha flight is a
symbol to go and retrieve Wolverine from
the x-men and the team consists of many
different extraordinary people
there's Guardian the original weapon
alpha who wears a suit of battle armor
allowing him to fly and manipulate
Earth's magnetic field there's North
Star who is a mutant with powers of
SuperSpeed and light generation and he's
also a game member of the team which
falls in line with what Kevin Feige is
wanting to do in the MC right now and
then there is Aurora who is the twin
sister of North Star who has the same
abilities that he has super speed flight
light generation and molecular
acceleration then we have sasquatch a
character who can transform into a large
beast very similar to sasquatch
there's also Snowbird who is a
demigoddess from Yellowknife who can
transform into animals of the north and
then there shaman who was both a skilled
doctor and a sorcerer so as you can
imagine this would be a pretty epic
fight between these characters and the
Hulk and apparently Alpha Flight is
going to be introduced pretty soon but
eventually and hopefully they will end
up fighting the Hulk when they both go
to try and retrieve Wolverine from
Canada and this could possibly be the
introduction of Wolverine into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we know by the
time that Wolverine makes his MCU debut
other mutants are definitely going to
have appeared in fact we're probably
going to be getting some mutants in
phase 4 but we all know that they're
going to be individually introduced so
hopefully by the time that we get
Wolverine in the MCU the MC will be
ready for an actual x-men film so let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below and let me know if
you'd be excited to see Wolverine at vs.
the Alpha Flight Team and then of course
for Wolverine to come right after that
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to stay up-to-date on
everything relating to the MCU and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
wolf wolf